chair
the old chair and we have chigalco
sergei
okay let's go
let's beat this guy
the o z
did you watch that series the oc yeah
no green oh i was just referring to
original chicago yeah yeah but i i've
never seen uh
you know it's pretty good serious
actually i i never certainly like early
2000's okay
i've been to oc orange county that's
what it's yeah isn't it yeah
where
is correct i might not have seen it for
real yeah was it good yeah it was pretty
good is it better than
how much your mother
no no
nothing is nothing is it better than
gossip girl gossip girl is it probably
not probably not
what's your favorite series minus from
the uh 2000s
um
i don't know right now
no i don't know i i don't i don't i
don't have enough time that's true to
know i gotta i gotta beat chicago
get back some mojo knight d4 is a move
we'll ask you when you're playing some
easier opponent
okay gotta get this majority going gotta
get this gotta get this
oh i belong to the piece but that's fine
you're still the mayor of blackwell
where you're going
oh he takes this one doesn't matter
just gotta
get this
knight c6 there's king knight for this
king c6
okay b6
yeah p7 take it
yeah okay